[Musique]
l'été rime avec thé glacé mais aussi
avec tisane glacée qui gagne en
popularité sur les tablettes du prêt-à
bois nouveau ce remarcher le rôti une
création québécoise de trois amis lequel
d'entre vous et inventeur du goût c'est
dû à un plat mais la scène est italienne
donc
c'est un peu dans notre culture
grammaire de quand j'étais jeune c'est
tout un cadeau mais aux jambes donc
puissant lit on en mange en salade ou si
donc c'est déloqué m'est venue l'idée
le trio a lancé au printemps dernier 3
tisane glace est original dans lesquels
on retrouve entre au romarin camomille
et puis son lit nous nos différences à
nous ce qu'est on est des tisanes à
cent-pour-cent à un fusil à froid à la
basse et épater votre café c'est juste
une alternative qui est puissante et le
marché la tendance actuelle mise en
effet sur l'aura des produits plus santé
moins sucré revirement depuis notre
précédent reportage sur le même sujet en
2011 alors que nous avions étudié 35t
glace et j'ai l'équivalent de 70 g de
sucre
ça équivaut à 14 père est athée
sept ans plus tard nous analysons près
de 70 t et autres infusion glacé l'offre
s'est carrément biffle et dans les
dernières années et surtout elle s'est
énormément diversifié on s'arrête plus
simplement à un thé noir citronnée créé
on nous offre même une variété de thés
une variété d'autres ingrédients de
fruits de plantes d'herbes aromatiques
bref c'est un univers de saveurs qui
nous est offert aujourd'hui
depuis cinq ans les ventes de thé glacé
prêt-à-boire au canada ont augmenté de
8% en 2010 est plus de 450 millions de
litres de thé glace y ont été vues soit
l'équivalent de près de 6500 pc il ya
vraiment un raffinement dans les
ingrédients et on lit plus juste dans le
thé noir ce qu'on préfère le thé noir le
thé vert le thé blanc le terreau ibos ou
qu'on soit poté du tout qu'on soit plus
cheap tisane
tout le monde y trouve son compte
aujourd'hui on retrouve des produits qui
sont sans sucre vraiment zéro g de sucre
25 grammes de sucre par portion de 250
mille îles et donc une tente donc ça
varie énormément yacht de tous mais
parfois les sans sucre signifie qu'il ya
un édulcorant d'agiter par exemple
stévia le sucralose ya même un produit
qui contient de l'aspartame
[Musique]
mais certaines boissons contiennent
toujours beaucoup trop de sucre ya des
fautes ça ressemble beaucoup à des
boissons gazeuses des boissons
énergisantes
on sait moins de 5 ans est relativement
nouveau le pistil temps déjà le format
de la canette
on est dans les produits extraits
directement les adolescents donc cette
gamme là où la gamme de risques qui sont
guillaume canet on a des emballages qui
sont très caloriques sont très attirants
le prix est accessible aussi pour pour
la cible un nouveau produit en
provenance des états unis
le moitié-moitié a fait son apparition
sur nos tablettes ont été sucre est plus
unie monal sucré ça fait un produit qui
est tout aussi sucré qui les ont donc
moi je le vois d'un point de vue
nutritionnel il pas plus intéressant
qu'il est en vie soyez attentifs car
dans une même gamme de produits il peut
y avoir de grandes variations ensuite
pour vraiment regardé en fonction de la
saveur que l'on choisit parce que les
toners les valeurs nutritives vont
changer on prendre break
et surtout méfiez vous des allégations
du type au gingembre amincissants ou
encore relaxe positivement certaines
entreprises sont même allés jusqu'à
proposer des promesses que j'aurais
envie de dire qu'ils sont presque de
nature ésotérique faut se dire les
vraies choses peut-être que l'ingrédient
de base qui a été utilisée pour certains
bénéfices réels
par contre une fois actées infuser et
diluée dans une bouteille de 500
millilitres est-ce qu'on peut encore
s'attendre ou à obtenir le même bénéfice
j'aime le poids au delà de ce qu'on nous
promet ou de ce qu'on nous indique sur
le devant en emballage toujours
intéressant de tourner la bouteille et
d'aller voir encore une fois la liste
d'ingrédients c'est là où la vérité se
trouve actuellement parmi les
informations on trouve aussi la teneur
en caféine le thé noir c'est souvent les
produits qui contiennent le plus de
caféine entre autres la marque pure leaf
qui en contient énormément
c'est l'équivalent parfois d'un café
donc on veut pas nécessairement offrir
s'annonce
on découvre aussi que certains thés
glacés contiennent du sodium gracieuseté
des additifs présent dans certaines
bouteilles ça fait une source de sodium
superflu dans l'alimentation crampons
c'est qu'on en consomme déjà tous trop
je pense que mieux vaut choisir ceux qui
en contiendra dans l'éventail de thés et
infusions glacé plusieurs se démarque au
final il ya des produits qui contiennent
la 1 6 gramme ou 1,8 g de sucre par
portion dre que c'est quand même des
produits qui sont qui peuvent être
intéressants alors qu'en 2011 on ne
comptait que deux thés glacés avec des
quantités de secret acceptable d'un
nouvel aujourd'hui c'est une vingtaine
de produits qui sont recommandés
finalement parmi ceux ci voici les coups
de coeur de nos deux spécialistes la
gamme de pure livre on a un vrai tu es
qui se trouve à être à être infuser donc
en profil de goût général quand on aime
le t on
on est quand même assez satisfait le
concept d'inclusion tisane
je les trouve très intéressante les
infusions de oasis je trouve que c'est
aussi une belle gamme point de estime me
parler pour ces ingrédients pour sa
valeur nutritive aussi pour gérer je
serais tenté si j'avais à choisir
[Musique]